what's going on guys this is Robin it's
like eight o'clock and I just got back
from seeing the Fantastic Four film and
and I got to tell you guys you know
whenever I've done reviews like I did a
review on on Avengers 2 age of Ultron I
did review on ant-man and those movies
were good I mean great they were
produced by Marvel age of Ultron was was
like watching 50 cars try to drive
through an intersection at one time it
was a calamity but the fact remains you
know that it was it was entertaining you
know to say the least and not in terms
of all the action all that kind of stuff
you know ant-man was a great film it was
the best solo film for a character since
Iron Man 1 if you're not counting
sequels you know man I don't know what
Fox is doing like I really don't know
what Fox is doing I don't you don't I
feel I feel like this movie was made on
a dare I feel like this like like this
reboot was made on a dare I feel like
somebody at Fox was like dude I dare you
to do a reboot of the Fantastic Four and
write the worst script imaginal because
that's exactly what this is this is the
worst script of Matt you know I recorded
this before and I tried to keep it calm
I try to keep it reasonable but I
couldn't I couldn't contain myself
because I watch movies like this and
it's not because I'm a kind of a fan you
know it's because I'm a person that's
seen that see movies like I've seen a
movie in my life I'm aware movies are
Bigfoot they exist all right like I've
seen them before and I know what a good
movie looks like and I know what a bad
movie looks like and I know what it
looks like when a studio tries like when
they even try to make a good movie like
like I've I've been I've been to the
bottom of Netflix all right I've I've
been through so many movies on Netflix
I've scrolled all the way down to the
horror section on Netflix now those of
you guys who are familiar with Netflix
now Netflix has all the best movies at
the top and they have all the shittiest
movies at the bottom I once saw a movie
on Netflix called Frankenfish it was
about a fish that was peep that was put
together with pieces of other fish and
it escaped and it ate
people and that was the plot of the
movie like that that was the basis of a
movie it was a Franken fish like it was
called freakin fish that movie was
better than this movie I mean and and it
sucks to say that it has a comic book
fan of sucks to say that this movie
sucked because I love going in and
watching movies about comic book
characters I distance myself I mean I
recognize it was based on the ultimate
universe I distance myself from the
ultimate universe and I said this is
gonna have some Alera T's but it's gonna
be a little bit different this is so far
removed it's not even funny and so here
here's my suggestion Fox I here's here's
what I want you to do alright I want you
to pay very close attention for for what
I tell you next because I'm gonna give
you a step-by-step guide on how to make
a good Fantastic Four film step 1 stop
making them step 2 go to Marvel step 3
give them the rights back step by step
how do you make a good Fantastic Four
film then you sit in your chairs and you
watch the movie that Marvel will make
and then you say so that's how it's done
like that is how you make a good
Fantastic Four film what you've done
here is not a good Fantastic Four film
so let's talk about this let's I mean if
we're gonna rail on fox and their
ineptitude and we're gonna we're gonna
basically compare them to a buffoon
trying to fit a square peg into a round
hole and not understanding why it's not
working then let's let's let's really
get into this so in the ultimate
universe and moral comics the Fantastic
Four it was a reimagining in the year
2000 and something or other it was the
fourth installment that was made they
lost with spider-man first and they went
with amazing store where they won with
Avengers now they didn't it was
spider-man first and they went with the
Ultimates and they went with the x-men
and they went with Fantastic Four was
the last one to be launched Brian
Michael Bendis and Mark Miller wrote it
and the first six issues were cool the
first six issues were interesting to see
a different Reed Richards who've been
picked on since school him and Ben Grimm
were friends since they were in grade
school so on and so forth and eventually
Reed Richards intelligence catches the
attention of the government and they say
we want you to come to this think tank
and Baxter building and all you're gonna
do is work with other kids and make
really cool stuff you're gonna work on
teleportation because up to that point
he'd been teleporting objects to the
negative zone but didn't know how to get
him back
didn't know where they were going he
just knew they were being teleported
that was good enough so he was at the
Baxter building of Marvel Comics he
branded a Susan storm he ran into Johnny
storm you know and you didn't see Ben
Grimm again until I get shoot number
five I he learned how to get and do cool
stuff but he was he was already a genius
like he was a child genius all right
Victor Von Doom was this arrogant brash
kid who was like you know I I just you
know I just want the world to see how
awesome I am like he had problems or
whatever it is and so on and so forth
anyway Reed Richards is been working on
a teleportation technology Victor Von
Doom comes along since your calculations
are wrong Reed Richards flips his [ __ ]
and then he says you know what Victor
Von Doom might be right and so they get
together they work together for the next
couple years BAM teleportation is born
in the Ultimate Comics for the Fantastic
Four that's the origin story of the
group what they've done in this movie I
can't even begin to event like it's it's
so [ __ ] like I'm not even mad about
Johnny Storm being a black kid that's
cool I'm fine with that Michael B Jordan
you're my homeboy now we'll go see
anything that you are in and I'm really
excited I'm really excited for greed
that's the least of my concerns for this
[ __ ] film all right pardon my
language that's the least of my concerns
for this film all right apparently dr.
Doom's in love with Susan and she
doesn't love him back
and so he's just gonna be emo and that's
his character like that is his character
dr. doom was one of the coolest
characters and in Marvel Comics and the
mainstream continuity the first thing
that that Fox should have realized when
they sat down and want to make a movie
based on the Fantastic Four from the
ultimate universe is it Doctor Doom and
those comics has goat hooves four legs
goat hooves his feet are goat feet
that's what happened to him when he got
transformed his skin turned to metal and
they said you know what like let's make
a movie about this alright but casting
that aside
alright casting that aside for a second
they came up with something called the
quantum what is the quantum portal or
the quantum zone or something like that
I can't but it's a freaking
teleportation device you walk into it
there and and you come out of it and
you're in a different place
Star Gate had it and they call it Star
Gate it was a cool name the quantum
thing
really look we're just trying to make it
sound as technology like as possible
it's got to sound really advanced guys
it has to sound really technology like
so we've lifts let's just use like the
like Quantum's something ladies and
gentlemen when you walk out of your
house and you walk outside your take
you're transitioning from one area to
the next
alright and and we call that a door like
we open it and then we walk through it
and then we close it again and it's
called a door and it's always been
called a door since whenever somebody
came along and said hearken alas let's
call this a door alright it's been that
way since however long it's been that
way alright why do you just call it like
a teleporter or a dimensional door or
something like that anything besides
quantum whatever not only that when they
get to the negative zone which is the
negative zone it's an alternate universe
it's been called the negative zone since
it was made by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
and they said let's call this the
negative zone it's been that way ever
since everybody calls it that and it's
you understand why would you not call it
a negative zone you have a movie about
it do the turn that they can stretch you
have a girl that can make herself
invisible and make force fields you got
a guy that sets them on some stuff on
fire and you've got a dude made of rock
all right is it really a stretch to say
we're going to an alternate reality
called the negative zone it sounds
cooler than planet zero
planet 0 sounds like a [ __ ] stage and
you know I don't know Mega Man which is
an amazing series Mega Man fans don't
think I'm not gonna I love Mega Man I
mean plainness it came out Mega Man is
amazing but it sounds like a video game
concept it doesn't I don't take that
seriously I'm stupid
alright once they get there reid is like
hey there's a device there and it's and
it's read and it's Susan and it's Ben
and Johnny and oh by the way by the way
the reason why they go is because the
government's like you guys can't go like
we're gonna send our own people search
me on why that makes sense it makes
sense to Fox which I guess happens like
it's I don't I don't know it's it's it's
it's it's like a Deadpool comic alright
no one understands what's going on
except for Deadpool he's the only one
that it makes sense to and it works so
if this doesn't work then we're
you Fox because no this is this doesn't
work you but you nonetheless I'm ranting
I'm kind of going on a tirade let's back
on let's get back on how shitty this
movie was so apparently they weren't be
they weren't supposed to go they decide
to go anyway when they get in there
there's like this is great big huge
structure let's collect samples and
stuff like that and then [ __ ] pops off
and it's like oh my god we got powers
and they bail out you know Victor Von
Doom gets left there you know and so
it's like alright well let's you know
let's figure stuff out they get you know
like the ultimate universe they get
teleported to different places whatever
you know they don't immediately show
back up where they were before and so
they finally find Reed Richards when
they find Reed Richards Susan storm and
Johnny Storm are working for the federal
government they give really they give
Reed Richards an outfit we personal
supposed to be though this is a
scientific genius this is like the like
the smartest people on the planet earth
and waffle comics alternate between
Victor Von Doom and Reed Richards and
you're gonna tell me that the government
could make a suit better than he could
please come on man it's like saying you
can make a it's like saying you know
more about astrophysics and Stephen
Hawking get the hell out of here like it
no one no one believes that but you know
nonetheless you know we're continuing on
we're gonna continue on so so finally
like the federal government's like like
if you want to reiax s than the planet
zero if you want to figure out how to
cure your ailment like you need to
basically work for us whatever they get
there
alright reads like fine whatever what
the hell so they get in there Victor Von
dooms still there alright he's still
inside the negative zoning he's
apparently lost his mind not only that
he's bonded with his suit and so Victor
Von Doom and the Fantastic Four looks
like [ __ ] like he looks like absolute
poop poop is what he looks like he looks
like poop it's pitiful it is it's it's
it's he he looks like a crash-test dummy
is what he looks like he looks if you
guys ever saw those commercials with
crash test dummies you know he looks
like a crash-test dummy that's silver
and green and that's that's that's
what he looks like that's that's that's
his physical appearance that's how he
looks so anyway so the villa the group
fights dr. doom they come out on top
whatever you know it's dooms whole idea
is well I I'm here's okay here's this is
basically do doom is like the ultimate
emo dooms like I don't like humanity so
I'm going to get rid of it and I'm going
to re might remake it in my own image
he's basically the kid in high school
who's like no one likes me so I'm just
going to like remake humanity so that
everyone likes me that's basically his
characters plot that's that's the plot
of the movie and and it's it's a
travesty it's it's it hurts to know that
movie exists not even from a comic book
standpoint from a person that see movies
like any movie pick any movie commando
Total Recall like anything with all
sorts of Egger because this eighty
movies were action-packed but they were
campy
I mean you pick any movie any any movie
out there and that's good that's a good
movie you know and and you sit down you
watch that and then you watch this and
it's just like what the hell happened
like what huh that's what happens that's
how it feels it feels like like I'd let
Fox house it and then I come back and
the house is burning down and it's like
what happened Fox like what happened
like I don't understand you know and
they're standing there and they've got
an apron on and they've got a bowl in
their hand and there's a spatula in the
bowl and nothing makes sense and you're
like what what and how in the hell could
you baking a cake turn into the house
burning down like I don't understand how
I don't understand how those that dog
don't bark all right that doesn't mix
you know and and I don't know make up
your own minds I guess go see the movie
if you want to but you know this is I'd
rather I'd rather sit in a dental office
and have a root canal done one day every
day for the next week
didn't watch this movie again well maybe
that's an extreme example I wouldn't do
that like I'd rather I'd rather watch
episodes of Barney then then do this
again I'd rather I'd rather watch Nicole
Simpson wrath then watch this movie
again like that it's it sucks it's
garbage it's it makes you it makes you
wonder why Fox makes movies like why do
you make films why do you why do you do
it like I don't understand why do you
even exist I mean here here I made this
for the first thing I try to do in the
last video and I couldn't I drove myself
insane please give the rights back for
the love of God give the give the
[ __ ] rights back like you can't make
a Fantastic Four film you can't and I
genuinely believe this if if Fox was
told make a good Fantastic Four film and
all of your wildest dreams would come
true they'd still find a way to [ __ ] it
up
like they'd still find it it's like they
it's like they it's like they write this
script just like be they make the script
and the script is pristine and the
script was like this amazing thing you
know it's it's this beautifully written
thing that that has so much potential
and it could be so amazing and then the
executives or whoever it isn't doesn't
charge sister Donna says okay guys how
can we screw this up and then they do
whatever that is that would that would
screw up the script and then they make
the movie on that script and then they
then they release the movie to us and
then they look around and and they're
like I don't understand why people hate
this film like I don't get it I get it I
understand it it's it's because you suck
because you suck
I don't know I feel like I'm rambling at
this point I'm gonna bring this really
one end but my consensus for this film
is is 0 out of 4 stars if our Siskel
nosis goes dead if I were you know Roper
I guess I'm gonna know if Jesus was
alive or if Eva's alive anymore I don't
watch those review shows but you know
whoever it is us doing that's doing the
thing that used to be Siskel and Ebert
if I were one of them I would I'd give
this movie 0 out of 4 stars I wouldn't
even give it one I wouldn't even give it
part of a 1 like I would just I'd say
you know for mercy's sake I'm gonna raid
it some people know but I'm not gonna
give you a rating this movies garbage
his movies crap yeah I'll catch you guys
later please